hi welcome to the reason live stream I'm
Zach Weissmuller and today we're going
to be talking about the recent collapse
of the Silicon Valley Bank of Silicon
Valley Bank and the subsequent
interventions from the FDIC
um also a couple uh you know other bank
failures that are that are relevant
we'll we'll be talking about and I'm
joined by two very knowledgeable guests
who help walk me through and walk us
through what exactly happened first
we've got Arnold cling uh an economist a
senior scholar with the mercatus center
he worked in the Federal Reserve System
and for Freddie Mac he writes a great
blog called in my tribe a sub stack that
I am a subscriber to welcome Arnold to
the reason live stream good to see you
hi hi Zach and I'm also joined today by
Lynn Alden of Lynn founder of Lynn Alden
investment strategies um and author of
the Strategic investment newsletter
which is a free
um investment advice newsletter Lynn
thank you for joining us as well thanks
for having me happy to be here
so to start the conversation um you know
there's a few competing explanations out
there of what exactly happened here with
Silicon Valley Bank in particular
um you know who's to blame why did it
happen and I think the best place to
start is just the basic question of you
know what happened I think most people
understand the concept of a bank run
people get nervous want to take their
money out the money's not literally
there in the vault but what is the
reason that there was a bank run Arnold
in in you know if you had to boil it
down what happens to Silicon Valley Bank
okay so the story I think goes like this
this is you know I've not been in the
bank I'm not a bank examiner I'm not a
bank auditor I only know what I read in
the papers so what I read is
uh
their
deposits shot up between 20 early 2020
and early 2022.
uh silicon they their customers were
Silicon Valley startups startups were
just getting flooded with money they
hadn't spent it yet they deposited with
the bank and then they would use it over
time to make payroll and what have you
uh then and so what what do you do with
all that money well they they said that
we'll be sort of conservative with it
we're going to invest it in treasury
Securities but short-term treasury
Securities hardly pay anything
long-term treasury Securities pay let's
say between one and a half and two
percent so we'll we'll go for that
um then 2022 comes along we get
inflation is
inflation fighting is the new thing at
the fed and long-term rates are no
longer at two percent they're more like
four percent what that does to the value
of of a two percent Bond when rates are
four percent is it roughly cuts it in
half
so their bonds weren't worth much uh or
worth weren't was worth as much as when
they bought them
then as I understand it the uh as the
Silicon Valley Tech boom
falter's the deposits start to dwindle
and now the bank has to do something to
deal with the deposit outflow how's it
going to pay its customers so it if it
sells the bonds it has to sell them at a
loss if it sells them at a loss it kind
of looks bad
uh so it's pretty reluctant to do it but
I think they ended up having to do it
um and then the old story of uh
you know I went bankrupt uh in two ways
slowly then suddenly and the suddenly
happened uh a few weeks ago the
depositors
these Tech firms that had deposits were
in the position of having very very
large Bank deposits and the federal the
insurance limit up until last week was
250 000 for a deposit and they might
have you know two million in deposits so
now they think they could lose quite a
bit if there's something wrong with the
bank they're hearing that there's
something wrong with the bank so what do
you do you go and you say I'm going to
take my excess out of the bank and put
it somewhere else where it'll be safer
and enough people do that and like you
know to the tune of like 40 billion
dollars and the and the bank is just in
no position to meet that is that yeah no
thank you for that and I'll I just want
to invite Lynn to uh you know add
anything uh to that explanation that you
think is relevant um I did you know
there's this this chart here that shows
um the uh this is kind of the banking
system as a whole to the point that that
Arnold was uh raising there about this
you know the bank buying up a lot of
bonds that then became less valuable you
see the um the amount of cash and
treasuries as a total percentage of Bank
assets across all commercial Banks and
um you see a spike there but let me uh
just invite Lynn to you know modify add
or you know fully agree with that
explanation well I think it was a great
explanation
um a couple details I think I could add
is that um you know Bank deposits across
the country went up pretty significantly
in 2020 and 2021 because of the stimulus
be a big increase in the money supply uh
but some banks got more deposits than
others because they were more like a hot
area so for example Silicon Valley Bank
at a bigger rise in its deposits than
the typical bank because Tech startups
were a very big you know uh thing in
that period and they did invest in those
long duration assets so what makes it
you know with that that chart you just
pulled up that shows how it's very
different than 2008 because 2008 the
problem was that so many banks made bad
loans uh and they had very little
exposure to cash and treasuries which
are considered some of their safer
assets uh and they instead were heavily
involved in in subprime mortgage and a
lot of those defaulted this time it
shows that the in some ways it's the
opposite problem they hold very very
safe assets uh it's just that the prices
of those assets
um went against them in Silicon Valley's
case they made a very big bet on
duration so Banks had to invest their
deposits their new deposits somewhere
and there's some banks like JPMorgan
that were conservative and they mostly
kept in short duration types of assets
whereas silicon on Valley Bank made a
very big bet on those longer duration
assets and so if you look at Banks
across the board Silicon Valley Bank had
unrealized losses on their on their
Securities that that you know roughly
equaled their total Capital meaning that
if they if they had to have a bank run
and have to sell those assets for a loss
uh you know deposits might not get every
every dollar back and you know the thing
is if they can hold those assets to
maturity
um you know some of them are can't
default other ones have a very very low
default risk but if they get their their
deposit funding pulled and they have to
sell a loss then they basically you know
that gets marked to Market and they have
a problem and the the last point I'll
make is that um you know because FDIC
insurers deposits up to 250 000 you know
a typical bank that just has a lot of
retail deposits that's a pretty solid
deposit base because people are not
going to freak out too much if they if
they think their bank has a problem
whereas the issue with Silicon Valley
Bank is it they had a higher than normal
percentage of uninsured deposits and
that's because most of their depositors
were businesses so there are some
businesses that would hold even tens of
millions of dollars in an account you
know the average deposit was not that
big but they you know they could be half
a million could be a million could be a
million and a half it could be 5 million
um and so if they perceive that
combination of high unrealized losses
which Silicon Valley Bank had more of
than normal and they have the
combination of mostly uninsured deposits
which which again Silicon Valley Bank
was a standout then that's a prime
target for a bank run because people
have a greater incentive to pull out and
then it causes a problem
so that it raises the question of which
you've already kind of answered why was
why was so much of their money in these
bonds um and one uh person who's been
very vocal about this uh I just pulled
up his tweet is palaji srinivasan
um uh who we've had on the show before
and um he says he he points the finger
directly at the FED for causing this
problem he says hey remember when Powell
said that he wouldn't raise rates in
April June July and October 2021 and
people trusted him and the fed and
bought bonds with billions in customer
deposits because of those assurances
well they got wrecked and that's how the
FED caused this crisis and he points to
this concept of forward guidance where
that you know the FED sends out these
signals of what they're going to do on
the part I have highlighted here says
when central banks provide forward
guidance into individuals and businesses
will use this information in making
decisions about spending and Investments
um what is your what what do you think
about uh Arnold uh what Bellagio's uh
the argument that he's making there
um I don't think that's the most
interesting or useful case to make
against the FED
um so let me back up a little bit we've
been talking about government bonds as
risk-free but there are two dimensions
of risk there's uh you know and and Lynn
mentioned both of them one of them is
credit risk which is means it'll default
and let's assume that there's no credit
risk
from uh from government bonds that's
that's it's that's your standard
assumption I won't depart from it but
there is this duration risk or interest
rate risk as if if you buy a long-term
Government Bond and rates go up the
value of your bond declines
so
um
you're taking you're taking interest
rate risk regardless of what Powell says
I mean anyone who says that you know
Powell can keep interest rates low
forever for as long as he wants uh
doesn't understand finance and so I I'm
not going to excuse anybody no no one if
someone came to court
you know and said you know I plead
innocent I listened to Powell you know
no one's I wouldn't accept that no no
one in finance would accept that but
let's back up a little bit
um I mean gosh there's so much Financial
history we could discuss I mean I I
think you know a lot of ways this is a
complete rerun of the Savings and Loan
crisis of the 1980s and a lot of my
perspective comes from that being being
old enough to have been a kind of an
active Observer of that
um
I don't want to go back that far right
now let's go back to 2008.
so the government decides to run big
deficits
and the Federal Reserve decides to do
this thing called quantitative easing
which and what quantitative easing
consists of is the Fed doing what svb
did
I want you to hear that the FED is
starts issuing short-term liabilities
called paying interest on Reserves
and it buys long-term assets including
mortgage-backed Securities and long-term
government bonds
at the time that was we were told that
was a temporary thing to deal with the
recession that followed the financial
crisis
it never stopped and then in
2020 the pandemic hits the government
blows out even bigger deficits
and we have even more quote quantitative
easing and they come up with even a new
tactic called reverse repo I won't
explain how that works but it's another
way where the FED is borrowing short and
lending long
as we speak the FED is the most bankrupt
Bank in the country
you know they're they're not going to
collapse they can always take more money
from the treasury but that is just
that's just the reality they they are in
the position of svb in terms of you know
the market value of their portfolio
um so I think you know when you go so
you know I think the process by which
SVP went down is as I described it when
you talk about blame then you have to
talk about who could have done
differently
and you know a lot of people would I
think this is really strange but a lot
of people would say that the uh
venture-backed
firms should have behaved differently
they'll say well they shouldn't have put
you know five million dollars in deposit
at this one bank they should have spread
their deposits around they shouldn't
have put the money in
and I've also heard the op sort of the
opposite which is they shouldn't have
all taken their money out
a couple weeks ago they should have left
it in so they shouldn't have put as much
in when they thought the bank was
solvent and they shouldn't have taken as
much out when they thought the bank was
in trouble so that's you know okay it
it's probably true that if they hadn't
done those things we wouldn't have had
this bank run but that kind of blame I
don't fit the blame that I think
I'm inclined to is to go all the way
back to that deficit spending and the
quantitative easing
uh there you're really putting the whole
country at risk there's no you know it
did it does not end well it it leads to
the inflation the inflation leads to the
high interest rates the high interest
rates bankrupt a bunch of companies
including a huge portion of the banking
system I think there's something like
still 600 billion dollars of embedded
losses in the in all the banks and only
about 2 trillion in equity so they've
lost about a third of their equity
um so all that I trace back to the loose
deficit spending and the quantitative
easing
Lynn I'm interested in this concept of
that Arnold mentioned in that answer of
the FED being broke and that having uh
you know that con having a contributory
effect here and and you in one of your
recent newsletters wrote about that
exact issue
um and and claim that that the FED is
broke uh you had embedded this chart
here
um showing basic well I'll let you uh
explain you know what this is but it's
showing in my understanding that the
money going from the there is no money
now flowing from the Federal Reserve uh
in into the treasury so could you give
us an explanation of what the situation
with the FED is right now and how it's
different from you know you know
anything in our our memory of of what's
been going on with the Fed
sure the Federal Reserve uh you know as
Arnold point out does have a similar
problem to a lot of these banks with the
key difference being that they can't do
a bank run on the Central Bank
um and so basically it's it's in a
position where you know they raise their
liability side uh interest rates much
higher uh compared to their asset side
which are longer duration fixed rate
assets and so you know for for most of
the FED history you know their
liabilities are things like banknotes
which don't pay any interest Bank
Reserves
um and reverse repos and then their
asset side is mostly treasuries and
mortgage-backed securities and those are
longer duration assets and so for most
of fed history for decades
um you know their assets pay a higher
average interest rate than their
liabilities and so they they make a
profit they cover their expenses and
then they send the remaining to the
treasury as a remittance
um whereas what we've seen since
September of last year was that because
they raised their interest rate side so
quickly now their liabilities are paying
a higher interest rate than their assets
it's actually worse than most banks
because most banks you know if look at
their deposit rates they're nowhere near
as high as current interest rates
um whereas the feds are so actually the
FED is operating at a loss and it has
something like trillion dollars in
unrealized losses uh with a key
difference being that you know you know
those like that liability side can't go
anywhere it can't get rapidly pulled
down uh the the main kind of downside
from that is that the treasury is no
longer getting their remittances anymore
and even if the FED would become
profitable in the future they still get
to pay themselves back uh before they
would resume those remittances so it's
basically contributing to the the fiscal
budget deficit and if we go back to the
prior question of you know who's to
blame here you know a lot of you see a
lot of people say just blaming the fed
or just blaming that bank and it's just
kind of a mix of a lot of factors
because the Federal Reserve did create a
very difficult operating environment
when you have say a rapid increase in
the amount of broad money supply uh very
low interest rates and you know when
asked about the rapid increase in the
broad money supply the the Federal
Reserve chairman said he didn't really
see this being inflationary then of
course it was inflationary and then they
you know they had they had to Pivot
their whole monetary policy they raised
rates they also sucked liquidity back
out of the the banking system uh and so
basically banks are undergoing this
gigantic whipsaw uh that is just a
difficult operating environment to work
through but then of course some banks
manage that risk better than others so
there are banks that manage their
duration risk uh very well and they also
choose their depositors I mean it's a
choice for Silicon Valley Bank to go
after those big business depositors that
are that are more of a Flight Risk and
it was their choice to invest almost
exclusively in long duration assets
which have bigger price swings and so I
it's certainly the case that that bank
made severe errors of judgment in terms
of risk management but it's also the
case it's just across the banking sector
it is just a more challenging
environment to operate in when you have
kind of record swings in interest rates
and uh you know just overall cash in the
system so if the government's Federal
governments you know deficits spending
policies and and the treasury's money
Printing and the Federal Reserves
interventions have created this whip saw
and uh you know certainly let's at least
say uh port fuel on the fire here and
and
um you know created a level of
uncertainty you know the the argument
that you were hearing from a lot of the
proponents of uh of bailing out the
depositors above that 250
000 minimum uh Beyond we can get to
we'll get to the you know systemic issue
later but you know one argument that
they that I heard being made was
basically
the government created this situation
and so it is kind of their
responsibility to swoop in and cover
those uninsured deposits
um do you buy do either of you buy that
particular argument
well I think that
you know from the standpoint of March
they had to do it I mean you know you
you know you could
you know this is one of those situations
where if they don't do it uh you know
you can you know
get your apple cart and take it out on
the street and that's how you're going
to make your money going forward I mean
it you're going to have you could have
really drastic consequences
however what is going to happen going
forward is
um I mean what you can think of
you can think of any kind of Deposit
Insurance or government guarantee as a
subsidy from the government to the banks
subsidies don't come free
the tax that pays for the subsidy is
going to be regulation and and there has
to be the these banks are what I call
zombie banks that is they have negative
net worth
the only way that uh Executives and
shareholders can come out out of it
really well is if they go out and take
big gambles and they pay off and if
those gambles don't pay off it'll be on
us the taxpayers to pay for it so that
has to be regulated they're going to be
put in a straight jacket so we are going
to have you know we don't see it
immediately but we're going to have over
the next few months the next several
years a much more regulated banking
system
uh I think somebody I read somewhere uh
I guess this was Robert Altman a former
treasury secretary saying we've we've
basically nationalized the banks and
that's one way to think about it we the
the the private sector financials the
the private part of the financial sector
has just shrunk dramatically and the
regulated part of the financial sector
has just gone up dramatically and we'll
just we'll see that over the next
several months and years
to follow up on that could you explain a
little bit more what you mean by the
phrase zombie Banks
uh it's just a bank where if you marked
all of its assets and liabilities to
Market or if you just said all right
today you just have to sell all your
assets and pay off your depositors you
know liquidate the bank uh if you tried
to liquidate the bank you would not end
up uh with any any anything left for the
shareholders and Executives so this and
I call it as it's called a zombie it's
not really my term it goes back to the
Savings and Loan crisis when the Savings
and Loans
were given the opportunity to keep going
even though that they were they were
insolvent they went nuts they bought
junk bonds they bought commercial real
estate and as one Economist pointed out
what what what the zombie Banks would
savings loans would do is they would pay
higher interest rates because they were
so desperate to kind of you know keep
gambling and they would buy weaker
uh invest in weaker loans and what does
that do to a healthy bank or Savings and
Loan well now they're you know their
ability to compete has gone away so
these zombies are really dangerous and
that's why uh there will be
justifiably very tight regulations
another
um you know another villain that's been
blamed I guess uh and this is coming
from the highest uh echelons of
government including uh Biden himself is
the concept uh or is deregulation
basically that back during the Trump era
uh the the the the assets mix that the
big Banks had to hold did not apply to
the smaller and mid-sized Banks and
we're going to just play a clip of Biden
here in a second um talking about uh the
role that he thinks that played and I'd
like to get both of your response to the
idea that um deregulation
um weakening Dodd-Frank is what led to
this problem
um Adam could you play that clip during
the Obama Biden Administration we put in
place tough requirements on banks like
Silicon Valley Bank and Signature Bank
including the Dodd-Frank law to make
sure that the crisis we saw in 2008
would not happen again
unfortunately the last Administration
rolled back some of these requirements
I'm going to ask Congress and the
banking Regulators to strengthen the
rules for banks to make it less likely
this kind of bag failure would happen
again
uh Lynn do you have any thoughts as to
whether because that that goes to the
question of you know the types of assets
that the banks are holding to make them
more resilient against Bank runs do you
think uh Biden has a point there
well I think one of the issues is that
the types of assets that cause this this
this particular banking problem are not
the same types of assets that cause the
2008 crisis for the most part those were
more credit problems these are more
duration problems and so some of the
regular a lot of the regulations put in
place during that time were more meant
for that that prior type of problem it's
also worth pointing out that you know
that you mentioned the Dodd-Frank uh
Bill uh Frank was on the board of
directors of Signature Bank which which
is one of the ones that was taken down
and so and a lot of it shows that it's
kind of a different set of problems
they're dealing with I mean ultimate at
the end of the day it's still the same
thing of trying to keep your assets
higher than your liabilities uh but
there's different ways that your assets
or liabilities can fall uh you know can
change and so some of the regulations
were basically not the same types of
regulations that would have prevented
this
um I think basically this this would
have been mitigated by say if they were
if banks are either required to or just
on their own you know if they want to
manage risk better does not take as much
duration of risk in addition to not
taking as much credit risk so a lot of
the prior regulations were focused
around limiting how much credit risk uh
Banks can take
and uh yeah I'm curious to hear your
thoughts on that too Arnold because you
know it kind of goes to your your
previous answer that you know you're
saying that we're we're kind of
barreling towards de facto
nationalization because there's just no
tolerance for any kind of risk in the
banking sector
um so is that uh is it plausible to say
you know is is Biden's argument that you
know weakening.frank uh is is a
plausible mechanism
um and what what do you expect to see as
the the regulations
um to you know further decrease risk uh
in small and mid-sized Banks what effect
is that going to have okay well the
going back to his argument
what is true
is that banks that are have over over
um well under Dodd-Frank banks that had
over 50 billion dollars in assets were
regulated differently than banks that
had under 50 billion dollars
and
he he mentions Trump and everyone
mentions Trump but actually it was a
bipartisan decision in Congress because
Congress was bribed you know you know
both parties were bribed uh to exempt to
raise that from 50 billion to 250
billion having said that we don't know
whether
regulating them differently would have
produced a different result
that's what no one has filled in and I
don't see any reason why that's true
there was nothing nothing to stop
Regulators from coming in
and
getting
Silicon Valley Bank to change its
behavior in fact the the rapid growth of
Silicon Valley Bank was the reddest red
flag a regulator could ever see so there
was just and and they could see the
balance sheet there was nothing stopping
them you can't just wave your hands and
say deregulation there was deregulation
they had the power the knowledge they
could have done it
conversely if it had been in the 250
billion dollar category the regulator is
going to let them go I mean if they let
them go as they stood they could have
let them go at 250 billion there's just
so that's what's demagogic about blaming
deregulation there was enough discretion
either above the 250 billion dollar
level or below it to make whatever make
whatever decision they wanted and they
made they didn't make the best decision
I'm also curious to to know what you
think the effects of because now it's
unclear that with with the FDIC stepping
in to cover all the deposits it's it's
unclear like
you know if other Banks go down what is
the what is the limit there
um and it and all of this raises
questions about what we call moral
hazard and that's a question that
um uh Larry Summers the former treasury
secretary former president Harvard
um said is not something to worry about
uh at this or you know he said in the
lead up to the bailout of the depositors
that it's not really a question that uh
can be front of mind for Regulators
we're going to just play that clip real
quick and then I'd like to get your both
of your reactions to the moral hazard
problem that this kind of intervention
you know might
uh my race uh going forward
I don't think this is a time for moral
hazard lectures or for talk about
teaching people uh lessons we have
enough strains and challenges uh in the
economy without adding the collateral
consequences of uh a breakdown in an
important sector
I agree with him uh you know Larry's my
age he remembers the Savings and Loan
crisis and he knows what moral hazard is
but he also knows that you know this is
this is an emergency that if you if you
let
the
uh if you stick with the 250 000 ceiling
obviously a lot of tech firms get wiped
out and you know I don't feel like they
deserved it and I don't think it would I
think it would have been horrible for
all the the people who worked for them
it'll cause cause all sorts of Chaos
uh and on top of that you have all these
other Banks where you know everyone can
you know can look at their financial
statements and see that you know a
certain percentage of them are under
water not as badly as svb but they are
under water and so you'll have Bank runs
all over the place Total Chaos in the
financial system so yeah to worry you
worry about moral hazard tomorrow
not today I don't think Larry would say
you never worry about moral hazard and I
think he knows you're creating a ton of
moral hazard and my point about zombie
Banks is that they are the ones who the
owners there are the ones who have lots
of moral hazard especially now that all
their deposits are guaranteed if they're
underwater they have nothing to lose by
taking money to Las Vegas and betting
and they have everything to gain and the
only thing that stops them from doing
that is regulation and that means that
the regulation is going to be tighter
and I think that that is going to last
forever there's this basic Trend that
government
Financial policy whether it's monetary
policy whether it's regulatory policy it
all the policies that survive are the
policies that allow government to
allocate credit to its preferred uses
especially to its own spending and
that's what we're going to see another
ratchet of that we saw a ratchet in 2008
where prior to 2008 the government did a
lot to support housing maybe too much I
I could argue that it's too much but
after 2008 it basically took the money
that would have gone into housing and
used it to finance its own deficits and
that's you know that's the trend that's
going to be exacerbated as we ratchet up
governments control over the banking
system
Lynn do you agree that that's going to
ultimately be the effect of this and if
so uh how do we do you have any ideas
about how to escape that or or how the
you know the banking are there any ways
around that or is this kind of just an
inevitable process that's uh we've got
to learn to live with
if you look back in the 1940s which was
the last time that federal debt the GDP
was as high as it is now Banks did
become basically these vehicles where
just a lot of government debt was was
monetized in there and that's it's
unfortunately kind of common to happen
in countries that have this level of
deficit and debt spending where the
banks essentially become like utilities
uh in that regard we've also seen as a
multi-decade trend of Bank consolidation
uh you know it used to be like tens of
thousands of banks now there's like four
thousand Banks the top 10 banks have
like half of all assets uh right now
there's a deposit of flight from small
Banks to Big Banks so that's it's a
continuing Trend
um you know as far as more Hazard goes I
mean at least the um shareholders were
not filled out right so there was no you
know there's still risk from investing
in a poorly managed Bank
um
you know as far as the positives go most
indicators show that they would have
gotten like 80 cents back on their
dollar
um if that were allowed to to play out
um you know it's not I don't think it's
a moral case that those depositors had
to be bail out but I from their
perspective of preventing future Bank
runs in an emergency I can see why they
wanted to do it yeah but like you know
most moral hazard decisions are kind of
that trend of fix the problem now uh and
then address the moral hazard later and
then never really address the moral
hazard
um either because they just don't or
because it's it's you know they've kind
of created a situation that we can't
really address it
um and so I I you know I think that's
just a general Trend that just keeps
happening yeah so do you uh think that
you know aside from the you know the
moral hazard question do you think that
it was necessary do you think uh is it
your opinion that this was a real
systemic risk and uh everything you know
that we would have just seen kind of a
Cascade creative Bank runs if the FDIC
hadn't intervened in this way I think
you probably would have I think there's
different ways that they could have
they didn't necessarily have had to
backstop the depositors in this Bank
yeah uh they did clearly had to provide
some sort of liquidity facility
um because banking system from its very
foundations not really a free market
activity to begin with
um and you'd have a Cascade where you
know a typical Bank a small bank has
something like you know
less than 10 of his deposits in in
liquid cash ready to go and so you could
get like a really bad liquidity squeeze
so clearly they had to provide some sort
of liquidity facility to prevent kind of
mass for sales Mass disruptions things
like that partially based on their own
actions that they themselves caused by
you know contributing such a volatile
monetary environment of rapidly
increasing you know Bank Reserves and
then Contracting Bank Reserves and
rapidly increasing it and falling
interest rates and all that but they
didn't necessarily have to backstop the
depositors that was kind of an extra
step I think they took to shore up
confidence in in further Banks and
prevent large-scale Bank runs so there's
clearly an array of choices they could
have made
um but doing nothing wasn't really an
option another choice I wonder about is
you know there's this there's reporting
from semaphore here that I'm displaying
uh why the biggest banks were first shut
out of bidding on Silicon Valley Bank
and uh the report says that uh you know
the largest U.S banks didn't submit a
bid for Silicon Valley Bank over the
weekend largely because they were
initially excluded from the sales
process by the Federal Deposit Insurance
Corp and ran out of time as a result I
mean wouldn't that kind of be the
Natural Market solution is that one of
the bigger Banks would just scoop them
up and what was the reason that what
would be the reason for the government
to block that sort of acquisition
well I guess I I don't sit in on those
meetings so I don't know but you have to
realize there's a negotiation that's
going to go on
uh the buyer is going to say all right I
want to be held harmless against certain
things and I want to have certain
sweeteners and the government who's in
the Pro you know who's basically taken
over the bank is a process of selling it
has to negotiate
um
and
there's actually so the perception among
people on the left is that the
uh in the 2008 crisis when when you know
a lot of banks were merged suddenly uh
is that the government didn't negotiate
hard enough and the perception of Jamie
dimon and some other Bankers is that the
government didn't negotiate in good
faith because uh you know he bought he
buys some bad Banks and then years later
uh those bad banks are fined for
behavior that took place before he
bought them and he's he has to pay up so
I don't know who you know who's right
and who's wrong in this particular
negotiation because like I said I wasn't
in the room
I'm curious to ask uh Lynn about
um you know the what you think about the
future of banking and um there's you've
argued in in uh
let me pull it up here um
there's you've said that ironically
Regulators want Banks to be reasonably
safe but not too safe and that there's
this kind of deeper question that
nobody's really talking about which is
one way to to avoid Bank runs would
actually to just be to hold more cash
reserves but that because of the way
that um the the Federal Reserve and um
the FDIC and just banking regulation
works it's a lot harder to set up and
get a an approved Charter if you run a
bank that way one example of that is
custodia bank which I'm showing here
which I believe holds actually over it
holds like 108 of its res of its
deposits in cash so people can always
get the bank or always get their money
out um theoretically and they pay they
they fund this through fees instead of
um you know uh loans so could you talk a
little bit about that that issue uh Lynn
of um fractional Reserve banking yeah
there have been a number of attempts
over the years for people to try to
create full Reserve Banks
um where you know instead of having just
percentage of deposits in cash they
would have at least 100 percent of
deposits in cash and and you know one of
the main examples was the narrow Bank uh
you know these start as as state Charter
Banks and what they what they do is they
apply to have access to the Federal
Reserve and the narrow Bank basically
just you know they wanted to take
deposits and then put them on deposit
with the FED as a bank reserve and
therefore from a from a depositor's
perspective you would just have like you
know you'd be basically banking with the
Federal Reserve except you'd have a thin
layer of of administrative overhead
between you and the FED because they'd
be operating you know the basic banking
services that you need
um and their their application was kind
of held in in stasis for a number of
years uh there's been course or you know
core things over that it's like
ironically they're trying to make from a
deposited perspective about as safe as a
bank you can make but they they get
criticized as it contributing to
systemic problems because then it could
suck deposits out from fraction Reserve
Banks towards that one at least for
certain types of depositors and then the
more recent case just this past year was
custodia Bank
um led by Caitlyn long and they want to
do more than just that but they're but
from the depositor perspective they do
plan they plan on putting 108 of
deposits at the Fed so that they could
withstand 100 Deposit Bank Run if it
were to occur again they would do other
services on the side but in terms of
that deposit and and what they do with
it uh and and they were also held for a
long time in stasis and then ultimately
denied
um and so and there's been other
attempts like that in other countries
too and in a low interest rate
environment they'd have to try you know
they'd have to charge a positive some
sort of fee to for those services in the
current environment they actually
wouldn't have to because Banks get paid
pretty high interest rates on their
reserves and so they could essentially
cover that overhead with those and then
even even potentially pass some deposit
uh interest onto depositors
um yeah and it's just it's not something
that the Federal Reserve has wanted to
exist for a variety of reasons
is what do you think about that um
Arnold is there a a sense in which you
know there that innovation in banking
has been stymied and that that is
contributing to a more fragile
environment
um like how do we break out of this you
know hyper fragile regulated
um system that we're we seem to be stuck
with right now and when headed more so
in that direction well John Cochran
who's an economist at the Hoover
Institution
uh has always been an advocate of what
you know Lynn rightly calls narrow
Banking and you can think of of banks as
serving two purposes one is they operate
a payment system so you know they make
sure that uh
that you can pay for things smoothly I
mean it's sort of you know when I was
growing up that meant checking accounts
and people writing checks and you know
now we've forgotten all about that we
you know use our phones or our credit
cards or what have you but ultimately
banks are kind of you know doing the
payment processing
um and what what John would like to do
is separate out payment processing from
what I might call real banking
uh so Payment Processing you know you're
just if if somebody's got a deposit with
you like Lynn said you have you put a
hundred percent backing of that so if
they walk to if every depositor walked
in today and asked for their money you
could give it to them you know you just
you know 100 Reserves
um and he wants that type of bank to be
required to be in the payment system so
he would actually like every Bank to be
like custodia Bank in that sense I don't
know the D all the details about
custodial bank but he would like there
to be the fed and then a layer of
private Banks operating the payment
system and depositors and that's One
banking system and then what I I'll call
this real banking because
uh banks are in the business of
uh putting on to their balance sheets uh
long-term risky assets and short-term
riskless liability so that's that kind
of mismatch is there
um
you want some of that banking to take
place I mean it just it helps the
economy but if they do too much like svb
did uh you get you know you
you get too much of a of a of a Minsky
cycle of people getting too exuberant
the economy doing really well and then
all of a sudden they they don't and they
don't take enough risks so
um
so that's a challenge
uh getting real banking right in some
sense you do want to subsidize it in
some ways you have to tax it by
regulation in some ways
um
we can talk about what might
be the optimal structure to kind of make
that happen but reality is government is
not aiming for the optimal structure
government acts as if it's aiming to get
the most credit for the allocated to the
channel to the
um its desired uses including its own
spending and that's that's the reality
that we deal with and that that's I
don't know how to fight that because uh
regardless of what they say they're
doing regardless of what we might want
them to do that's what they're doing
well so there's one line of argument
that I think is worth getting into here
because it's it's the Bitcoin solves
this line of argument that you have to
totally exit uh the banking system the
banking cartel because there is no all
the incentives are lined up in the way
that you've just laid out for the
government
um uh Arnold what uh say you to that
Lynn is you know the the kind of Bitcoin
maximalist approach the only way out of
this to to force the issue
well I mean I think part of the reason
fractional Reserve banking exists
because you've always had the you know
historically it it grew over a
gold-based system because you had that
mismatch and speed gold was slow
um and people needed services on top of
their gold but then that creates a
mismatch what you know once a bank
realizes that only a certain percentage
of their depositors are likely to ever
withdrawal at once they start realizing
that they can make a profit by using
that liquidity difference to their
benefit and once One Bank does that they
create cost pressures that that you know
incentivize a lot of other Banks to want
to do it
um I think it's the problem in the
current environment is that they won't
even let a full Reserve Bank exist as an
option
um whereas I think I think the you know
I think it's reasonable for people to
have that choice but that's just the
current incentive structure that they
have in place I can see why from the
Central Banking perspective they don't
particularly want that even though
obviously from a user perspective there
are people that want it um a lot of
people just say why can't someone you
know if they have have more than a
quarter million deposits why can't they
just spread that around and one way to
think about it is is businesses
businesses have a lot of incoming and
outgoing cash flows they generally need
to hold larger amounts at a given time
and if they have multiple bank accounts
that's more overhead to manage there's
also things that can do like sweep extra
funds into money markets sometimes
there's limits on how many times they
can do that so they can still get caught
with um you know some of their deposits
uh uninsured there's also fintech layers
so that they can like say from their
perspective it looks like they're
running on One bank but behind the
scenes they're using like you know 10
different bank accounts and so their
their overall FDA is sure insurance is
limit and a lot of those things are
basically go around the fact that you
know a full Reserve Bank doesn't
currently exist in the system as far as
Bitcoin is concerned I think um
when you look at that it helps look
globally right so in the United States
you know we're talking about bank
failures in the United States but I mean
there's few places in the world where
you'd want to hold money in a bank more
than the United States I mean you know
maybe Switzerland a few others but
especially the long tail of
um you know developing countries uh
which is where the majority of people
live uh their banking systems are
notoriously unreliable uh I think I
think with safety and almost they
calculated that the average uh currency
growth rate of a country was 29 per year
compounded and that's obviously some of
them are much higher than that most of
them are less than that the average
developed Market currency grows it
broadened my supply of like high single
digits
um and so a lot of people face just one
is ongoing currency problems and then
two if they try to hold something like
dollars in their bank account they're
they're liable to have those be
confiscated that happens quite often
um you know I know people in Egypt that
are literally just holding cash dollars
uh physical
for lack of knowing what else to do with
it in in Egypt right they don't really
want to hold the Egyptian pound it just
got cut in half
um they don't particularly want to put
those dollars in Banks uh you know
sometimes they hold gold and things like
that
um and then they hold cash dollars so
they're getting
all the inflation of the dollar without
the interest rates in any way to kind of
offset that
um and so I think it's natural that in a
lot of these countries you've seen
interest in either stable coins which is
a way to access dollars outside you know
they have counterparty risks but they're
those counterparties are outside of
their host country so if you're a
Nigerian and you want to hold dollars uh
stable coins have been an option uh and
then Bitcoin is one that there's no
counterparty risk but then instead you
have to take on the volatility risk and
that the overall risk of the network
either you know will keep growing as it
has been or will stop growing as has
been uh and so I I do think that Bitcoin
is an interesting solution in the long
term and but people obviously have to
manage their exposure to it because you
know you while nobody can you know if
you hold the private Keys nobody can
take your Bitcoin but your Bitcoin can
fluctuate dramatically in terms of
purchasing power in a given time period
what what do you think about that Arnold
uh yeah I know you've been a crypto
skeptic you've described uh
cryptocurrencies as largely a pyramid
scheme but Bitcoin you know some Bitcoin
as viewing it as a hedge against Real
instability in the banking sector does
that make sense to you that that doesn't
excite me I think the use cases are more
like what Lynn said for people who don't
have a reliable government and banking
system
uh the uh
well put it this way if our banking
system collapses
I I think I think the best hedge against
that is to have a vegetable garden okay
because if the banking system collapses
you know are we going to have an
electric grid are we going to have the
internet uh and without those are we
going to have any Bitcoin so
um
yeah uh so I I can't see that one
the the you know um speaking of crypto
there is a a lot of crypto enthusiasts
believe that what is happening with some
of these Banks is constitutes
part of an ongoing war against crypto we
we had uh Nick Carter on a few weeks ago
who put out this idea of operation choke
point 2.0 which this time is focused on
basically clamping down on
cryptocurrency uh this is all of course
in the context of post FTX collapse
um you know you mentioned Lynn earlier
Barney uh Barney Frank's uh Bank
signature or you know he's on the board
at signature and he has claimed that the
reason that Signature Bank was seized by
a New York state agency is not because
it was insolvent he said it was not
insolvent but that what part of what was
happened was that Regulators wanted to
send a very strong anti-crypto message
do you think that the government is
currently sending that message and if so
why
I think there's Merit in the observation
that some of the um crypto participants
have that that some of these Banks were
uh treated uh differently so basically
the Signature Bank uh Silicon Valley
Bank and silver gates are um you know
well two of them uh had a big crypto
business Silicon Valley Bank Less so but
it it was still somewhat crypto friendly
um and those were you know among the
three that that failed uh signature
bank's the one that's under scrutiny in
the way because they weren't necessarily
insolvent they were illiquid because
they had a similar problem where most of
their depositors were businesses and
therefore uninsured and therefore
you know I had a Flight Risk
um the the interesting thing is that
both silvergate and Signature Bank
operated uh these kind of real-time uh
transaction uh services so if if a
company deals with crypto trading the
problem is that crypto trades 24 7 and
Banks don't
um and so what those Banks would do is
like you could you could send money 24 7
to like other uh users of that bank and
therefore money dollars could move
around or at least you know claims on
dollars can move around as quickly as as
crypto could and so that was an
important part of the liquidity for for
the trading ecosystem and what we've
kind of seen in the past say 48 hours or
so is that on the on the negotiations
around purchasing signature Banks assets
um one of the conditions and this is
reported by Roy Reuters is that they
can't buy the crypto assets that
basically that that service that they're
operating is something that the federal
government does not particularly seem
interested in allowing to continue to
exist
this is also we're at so I do think
there's Merit in the choke point thesis
and that is worth people pursuing
getting transparency on
um you know seeing if there's kind of
unfair crackdowns on an industry by
industry basis
um but I think it's also worth pointing
out that in this case Bitcoin companies
and crypto companies are kind of it's
almost like a Venn diagram that overlaps
a little bit in the middle but they're
actually quite different in the sense
that most of the crypto ones are very VC
funded uh they're essentially on
registered Securities in a way they have
rather centralized teams and a lot of it
is very active in that trading
environment which is inherently kind of
speculative whereas in the Bitcoin space
um they're less so reliant on those
those
um you know kind of trading uh rails
that say silvergate and signature uh ran
and they have less concentration of
their you know what what whatever
companies do exist in the Bitcoin space
less of their funding is kind of
concentrated in those hubs
um and so it's less kind of a direct
attack on bitcoin but I do think it's a
somewhat of a Crackdown on some of the
the crypto VC space and then as far as
as kind of Bitcoin as alternative asset
goes I mean let's say you did have a big
problem in a country and everybody needs
vegetable gardens one of the kind of the
useful aspects of Bitcoin is that if
someone has their private keys they can
leave uh that region and go to another
region and then be able to access their
Bitcoin in that other region in a way
that you know you can't bring cash to an
airport you can't bring gold to an
airport and so for example I know
I know someone from Venezuela that left
the country with his Bitcoins and he
would not have been able to do that with
with gold for example because you can
bring your Bitcoins by remembering 12
words
um as your as your seed phrase and you
know you can reconstruct your ability to
access Bitcoin when you get away so you
know I think that's when you when you
kind of look at that global scale I
think is when you can see why bitcoin's
interesting whereas in the context of
developed countries we mostly treat it
like a portfolio asset you might have
say a Bitcoin slice next to your stock
slice next to your T bills you know
people treat it as like a slice and
diversified portfolio whereas people in
some of these other types of countries
treat it as more of like an actual
utility asset that they find useful in
in certain contexts where say gold or
even physical cash dollars would not be
let me ask you about that uh Arnold as
our kind of uh resident crypto skeptic
here you know do you view these as
fundamentally different like you know
Bitcoin uh is different from ethereum is
different from nfts is different from
whatever token FTX came up with
um there there's clearly a lot of
Suspicion now um in the government of
kind of crypto as a broad asset category
um but you know is there in a sense are
things just being painted with two
brought a brush at this point or or is
it warranted that the government is
really taking a much harder look at the
entire space right now
um that that's like a probably a
20-minute question to which I'm probably
not even qualified to answer
um let me see if I can take a pick a
slice of the question to answer
um
uh
I guess you know an interesting question
is how will
with crypto assets intersect with the
what I call the formal banking system
you know the the system that government
supervises and cares about
um and that's a question that people in
government I'm sure are asking uh and uh
I don't know what the right answer is I
mean the the Venezuelan taking Bitcoin
across the border
uh is not really interested in being
involved certainly in the Venezuelan
government banking system
uh they're interested in escaping it
uh and if your motive is to escape
government well government's not that
motivated to help you
and it may be motivated to harm you and
I guess you shouldn't be surprised at
that I guess the other aspect I'll take
is uh so there's sort of a dilemma for
the crypto people do you want to be
friends with government or enemies and
if you want to be friends how friendly
so that the other dilemma is centralized
versus decentralized so the promise of
Bitcoin certainly is decentralized uh
maybe it's true with some of these
others but the more decentralized it is
it seems like the harder it is to use
and the more profit opportunities there
seem to emerge in coming up with
centralized Solutions and these
centralized Solutions tend to bring in a
lot of the fragility and uh potential
problems that you're trying to get away
with with the decentralized system so
resolving that issue I think is tough
and I don't claim to have an answer
fair enough as we wrap up here let me
bring in one of our audience questions
and then I want to zoom out and look at
the economy as a whole at interest rates
at
inflation and how these things are all
interacting and get both of you to talk
a little bit about where you expect
things you know might be headed from
here is is it all doom and gloom or is
there you know hope of the soft Landing
that we've been told about uh several
times
um but let me bring up this question
first from Benjamin Dover who says is
there a systemic risk of Deposit
Insurance being substantially weakened
by covering SVP deposits
um either of you have an opinion on that
my first thought is no that I mean as
Lynn pointed out they weren't svb wasn't
that far underwater to begin with and
you know there's a lot of money in the
Insurance Fund so that's the I don't
know Lynn agrees or not but I I agree I
think I would separate the theoretical
from the Practical so theoretically FDIC
insurance only covers less than one
percent of total deposits and a little
bit over one percent of insured deposits
and so in theory it's always this kind
of thin layer of protection uh but in
practice uh since 1933 there's never
been a insured deposit that they didn't
cover
um and one of the I think one of the few
bipartisan things would be essentially
backstopping FDIC that seems unlikely to
be the thing they let go so I I think in
practice
um
I don't really have I I would assign a
very very low probability that FDIC
insured deposits would would fail
so uh to to wrap up here I want to bring
up this this uh chart uh from the Board
of Governors and the treasury and uh all
of our slides by the way are linked uh
below if anyone wants to see the the
data we're using here but
um it's got several lines here and you
can see a sort of unprecedented at least
in this snapshot here situation where
the Blue Line the federal debt to GDP
ratio is you know higher higher than
ever
um the that's you know new new territory
here at the same time the FED is trying
to tame inflation which is the green
line you see it spiking up down there
and uh using uh higher interest rates
which is the red line
um also you know obviously on an upward
trajectory so given this what looks to
me like a rather unprecedented situation
where do both of you expect this is all
headed I'll start with Arnold and then
let Lin uh weigh in
uh I wish I knew
um
I'll I'll play the old man again
um and take you back to an incident in
1970.
that is covered in a book called Super
money
uh that was I think came out in 72
um Penn Central Railroad went bankrupt
in June of 1970 and exactly this type of
scenario played out that the Fed was in
the middle of trying to stop inflation
and
they looked at the situation over the
weekend and they said
if we don't do anything it'll be the
apple cart scenario you know it'll be
another Great Depression we can't we
have to do something
so they in in
the telling of the story in this book
you know they just got on the phone and
called every bank and said just make
whatever loans you need you know we're
not you know we're not trying to
constrain credit anymore
um what followed
where things like the New Economic
Policy of Richard Nixon which devalued
the dollar and he tried wage and price
controls and inflation kept getting
higher and higher and you know the 70s
were not a good story
are we headed to the same thing are we
you know there's a lot of talk about
abandoning any effort to fight inflation
I think and I think John Cochran would
think that any effort to fight inflation
has to include a serious effort at
reigning in the deficit and not just any
one year but all the out years and that
includes Social Security and Medicare
are we going to see that probably not so
does that mean we're going to relive the
1970s with a lot of floundering and you
know random policy changes that don't do
anything and you get a lot more
inflation so I anyway it's it's not an
easy thing to answer I just say that the
one precedent that comes to my mind says
watch out for you know lots more
inflation and more troubles and just to
be very clear about that what why is it
that bringing the deficit and eventually
the debt under control is the essential
component there from your Viewpoint
because ultimately that's what
you know how the government injects
money or wealth into the economy is by
just running these deficits and if you
don't and and
you know how do you how do you get rid
of government debt you can deformally
default you say wake up tomorrow and say
sorry bondholders you're not getting
anything
or you can actually cut spending raise
taxes or you can inflate it away
there's no sentiment to
formally default there's no sentiment to
bring the deficit under control so what
you're left with it seems to me is
inflation
and Lynn what have a nice day
bye no uh let's uh I'm sure you're going
to cheer us up here
I think unfortunately not I think I have
to agree with the inflation thesis
um one I guess a bit of color I'll add
is that the 1970s when you look at that
inflation Dynamic even though there was
a deficit problem a lot of it was from
very high levels of Bank lending that
was our fastest pace of Bank lending in
in U.S history and that really coincided
with with uh you know people that were
born and you know the baby boomer
generation entering their home buying
years and so you had that surge of
demand at the same time as you had
obviously the oil uh Supply constraints
and so a lot of the there's more money
creation from Bank lending than there
was from fiscal deficits whereas if you
look back further to 1940s uh that was
an equally as inflationary decade and
there's very little Bank lending it was
almost entirely a fiscal driven
phenomenon the busy massive deficits to
fight the war were highly inflationary
um and the current environment we find
ourselves in the 2020s in many ways is
more similar to the 1940s which is the
vast majority of the money creation and
the inflation was not because of
excessive Bank lending I mean Bank
lending levels are pretty normal and
almost all of it was from unusually
large fiscal deficits that we'd not seen
since World War II as a percentage of
GDP and I also I don't really see a
realistic path to cutting that anytime
soon because you have social security
Medicare that's a very popular programs
um uh it's just it's it's you know kind
of that third rail that that politicians
don't want to touch if you have military
spending you know we have 750 foreign
military bases over 800 billion a year
on that but especially what's going on
geopolitically it's it's you know that's
not likely to be cut anytime soon
um and also then you have a lot of
politicians that some of them do want to
raise taxes other ones don't uh it seems
like there's enough of a mix that it's
it's taxes are unlikely to go up
materially
and so I think that you know we look at
the 1970s they because that the GDP was
so low one of the things they were able
to do was sharply raise rates to try to
bring down Bank lending get the positive
real rates
um and that helped get inflation under
control whereas 1940s because you had
over 100 debt the GDP
um it was very hard to raise rates and
so instead they just kept rates low
despite High inflation and anyone
holding dollars bonds uh and things like
that really got devalued on an ongoing
basis and so I think that unfortunately
2020s are kind of shaping up in that
direction where you know they might get
the positive real yields for brief
periods of time uh especially if they
you know they're willing to cause a
recession to do it but I think the
majority of the decade probably is just
going to be have a tough time getting
inflation under control because I don't
think they're going to get the deficits
under control and I also don't think
that interest rates are going to be high
enough to compensate people for it
have a nice day yes our closing messages
hold on to your hats folks uh I wanna
but I do want to thank uh Lynn Alden and
Arnold Kling for joining me to talk
through all this today it's been really
informative and I recommend subscribing
to uh Lynn's newsletter subscribe to
Arnold's uh sub stack and of course
subscribe to reason TV we'll be back
here next week uh with another
conversation uh we're gonna be talking
with Ethan nadelman about the case for
legalizing all drugs maybe that will
help uh you know numb some of the pain
going into this but uh thank you Arnold
thank you Lynn thank you to Adam
Sullivan our producer and thank you to
our audience for tuning in we'll see you
next week